welcome to the billionaire mindset your
30-day journey to thinking
like a billionaire now you can just
watch this video or if you want to sign
up for the entire series for
free and get the bonus pdf companion
calendar
check the link in the description below
today is bonus day
one and we're gonna learn from the
seventh eighth and ninth
richest people on the planet larry
ellison
larry page and sergey brin enjoy
a lot of times my issue is people are
not setting
goals that will be something that
somebody who becomes rich or could do
anything
you got to be excited about working on
that for ten years
so you gotta have a big enough goal that
you know you attract the best people and
you retain them
and you keep them focused and in my
experience you don't go wrong you know
maybe you don't hit it
next year or maybe you fail entirely and
you
discover something more exciting to work
on with the same set of people
one of the things that i'd been through
as a student uh was some leadership
training and one of the things they
taught us was to have
to not be afraid of failure and and
instead have the goal to fail a lot
quickly and then eventually you'll
succeed and i sort of took this to heart
and they also had a slogan called
healthy disregard for the impossible
and they actually made you write down
sort of the things you would do that
were kind of impossible but you thought
you might really accomplish
and that's really stuck with me and in
everything that i've tried to do
and i think it was very very close that
we wouldn't have started the company
and i think there are many of you out
there in sort of similar situations
you know do you want to take a little
bit more risk uh do you want to try
something out and
you know even if you don't succeed we
should actually tried many things that
didn't work
um you know google happened to work
pretty well uh but there are many things
that we did that didn't
but we don't worry about those right
because we we tried many things
so i just encourage you to take a little
more risk uh in life and i think
uh if you do it often enough they will
really pay off this is how we keep our
innovation running
i think usually as companies get bigger
they find it really hard to have small
innovative projects and we had this
problem too for a while and we said oh
we really need a new concept you know
the google ads that's a small project
that we're not quite sure if it's going
to work or not
but we hope it will and if we do enough
of them uh some of them will really work
and turn out such as news
but then we had a we had a problem
because then we had over a hundred
projects
and i don't know about all of you but i
have trouble keeping 100 things in my
head at once
and we found that if we just wrote all
of them down
and ordered them and these are kind of
made up don't
really pay attention to them for example
the the buy iceland was
from a media article we would never do
such a crazy thing but
um in any case
we found if we just basically wrote them
all down and ordered them
that most people would actually agree
what the ordering should be
and this was kind of a surprise to me
but we found that as long as you keep
the 100 things in your head
which you did by writing them down that
you could do a pretty good job deciding
what to do
and where to put your resources and so
that's basically what we've done
uh since we instituted that a few years
ago and i think has really allowed us to
be innovative
and still stay reasonably well organized
yeah i talked a little bit about
focusing the company
and uh you know i think that uh
i want to talk a little bit about making
some big bets and
you know we always try to concentrate on
the long term uh what we're doing for
the long term
and you know i think that you know uh
many of the things we started up that
are really big now like chrome were seen
as kind of crazy
uh when we launched them and so how do
we decide what to do
what do you know how do we decide what's
really important to work on
well i like to call the toothbrush test
so the toothbrush test is do you use it
as often as you use your toothbrush
and for most people i guess that's twice
a day raise your hand
twice a day yeah okay most people
so i think you know we really want
things like that and i think things like
gmail obviously
i use much more than twice a day uh
and youtube you know i think that uh
those things are amazing and i think
that uh
you know we look at things like youtube
people thought oh you guys are never
gonna make money with that you bought it
for 1.4 billion dollars
uh you know you're totally crazy and we
were reasonably crazy but it was a good
bet
and uh we've actually been doubling
revenue every year on youtube for four
years
and uh actually if you're doubling
things it starts to add up pretty
quickly
um even no matter where you start from
so i think that's a good example of the
how
sort of our philosophy is that we see
things that people use a lot
uh that they're gonna that are gonna be
really important to them
and we think that usually you can make
money from those things over time
you know a well-run technology business
can be monetized over time i think a lot
of companies not so much these days but
still get started because some space is
hot
and honestly i don't think that's a very
good reason to start a company
and in fact um we see you know hundreds
or thousands of people
come to us who want to commercialize
something or want us to collaborate with
their business
and we actually look at these and i look
at quite a few of them
and my guess is like one out one a year
we are interested in
so you know the the trick is to have the
one that somebody's going to be
interested because it's a good idea
and not to you know be one of the
thousands that come through all the time
and i think you know if you're the one
good good deal or you have a good idea
you really
understand the area you're in you know
the funding environment doesn't matter
it doesn't matter whether it's a hot
area
you know i guarantee you'll be able to
get people interested in helping you out
and i think for all of you there are
many areas
where there's leverage available in the
world where you know one or two people
a good idea a lot of hard work can
really make a difference there's many
many things like that
and it's good not to forget that but
it's good to look for those things
google's mission is to organize the
world's information and make it
universally accessible and useful
and one of the things that surprised me
that's a very broad mission it's a lot
of work
we're not going to achieve it anytime
soon right
it's almost an impossible task but it's
an exciting task and one that you can
get other people
excited about and they can help you and
one of the things that all surprised me
is
sometimes easier to do something that's
harder
because other people get excited about
it and you can get much more resource
you can get tremendous resources to
solve a hard problem whereas you might
only get minor resources
to solve a small problem anything you
can imagine probably is doable
right you just have to imagine it and
work on it
and things that we thought were almost
impossible
so we we were interested in machine
translation there's services on the web
we had licensed one that which could
translate between different languages
and obviously for search you know if you
can't if the information's not in your
language
we can't find it for you and most
information is not in your language
right this is sort of a by definition
and so we thought well it'd be great if
we could provide search results from any
language for any query
and so we're really focused on that
problem and uh we focused on it and we
developed
google translate and we we found some
machine learning researchers and we said
do you think you can translate you know
between any languages
and do it better than an average human
translator
and they said they laughed at us they
said no we can't possibly do that but
they actually were willing to try and uh
you know six years later we can
translate between 64 languages
and it's amazing actually we're better
many languages were better than an
average human
uh translating we do it instantly and
for free
and between those 64 languages we can
translate between any two of the
languages so we have something like four
thousand
languages we can translate between and
so i'm just trying to give you i guess
i'm tremendously optimistic that
whatever things we try to
challenge whatever challenges we try to
to take on
we can solve with a little bit of
concerted effort and some good
technology
and i think that's a really exciting
place to be in the world
so i think we want more people working
on it we want to have more ambitious
goals
and i think with that we could easily
double kind of human progress
and the rate at which we're we're
developing so i'm going to switch gears
and talk really briefly about
entrepreneurship
so i'll try to give you some of the
things i think are really important that
other people won't tell you or won't
stress as much
and one of those really just don't
settle it's very very
very important if you're starting
company to have the right people
involved and i can't stress that enough
i've been you know enormously happy with
people we've had involved at google with
my co-founder and with eric
and we took a long time to find these
people actually
i've been working with sergey for a
really long time but eric took us over a
year to hire eric
and just generally having great people
involved
that you really like and that are
compatible with you and all those things
is tremendously important
you're never going to question the
equity you gave up or any of the other
things
so i can't stress that enough the other
thing i think we really benefited from
is being real experts
we worked on google for many years at
stanford
before we started the company and that
was a pretty nice position to be in we
understood sort of all aspects of search
we talked to all the search companies
for many years um we really we really
knew a lot about what's going on
and you can do that pretty cheaply right
it's just your labor right you can
invest a year or two
or three years and really learn
something very very well
before you start having hundreds of
people you know working on the problem
yeah i was just going to say you know
recently i reorganized a bit to focus on
product areas
and i think you know in any company as
it grows you know if the company's not
static
which shouldn't be you know as it grows
and
it changes uh you know you need to
reorganize it and just question
is you know are you keeping ahead of
that and
uh looking at the our business is pretty
complicated we have all these different
products
we have advertising we have search we
have chrome we have android
uh we have youtube and so on uh and
those things are actually relatively
different uh have different different
things going on so i think uh you know i
kind of moved that up a level in the
company and made sure that we were super
focused
in each of those areas on what our user
experience was
and i think that's that's helped just
generally as you switch to company as we
got more offices
you know as we got time zone differences
we had to change how we did our meetings
uh change how we do our employee
communications and so on
so so i just think you know and our
technology business is growing rapidly
just need to make sure you're changing
everything you know you're being
responsive to that change and changing
everything you know every year
or else you're just not keeping up with
it i want to talk about dreams for a
second
and in my case literally a dream
when i was in college i was sure
that i'd been admitted by a clerical
error
probably a computer error and because of
that
i had an irrational fear i'd be sent
home
on the bus and sergey's here knows this
is true
[Music]
but it turns out because of that anxiety
i woke up literally with a dream
it was kind of a strange dream it went
like
i think i could download the entire web
onto some old computers that were lying
around
and that would probably seem pretty
crazy to most people
but i stayed up a couple hours in the
middle of the night doing some math
and it seemed actually pretty plausible
while assuming actually it didn't keep
any of the web pages
you only kept the links
and then sort of figured out given all
that data i thought it would take a
couple weeks
and i told my advisor that
and he just sort of laughed at me and of
course took
a year or two but at the end of that
[Applause]
we had a way to rank web pages and no
thoughts to search at all and eventually
search entered the picture and you know
the rest
and that became google
[Applause]
so i'd like to encourage everyone to
follow their dreams
i think running company startup is
really a big commitment
um takes a lot out of you out of your
life to do well i think
i'm not sure the same is true for
companies as they get bigger
so i'm not sure that's for everyone some
people are good at starting things
i'm not good at finishing things
and i think organizations have trouble
recognizing that too i think
um and those are difficult transitions
for people
um in general i think you know if you
have a project or company
and it can have stable leadership you
know over 20 years that's better than
not
it's often easier to have aggressive
goals
and what that means is a lot of times
people
pick very specific things they want to
do because they think they'll be easier
to attain
what happens if you're being more
specific you know smaller markets that
kind of thing
you also get less resources so the
question isn't really how much resource
you need the question is you know can
you make a really good case for what
you're doing
um does it make sense do you have a
really big advantage like if you're
building robots that are
10 times less complicated than your
competitors that's probably a good
business right
and maybe it takes a lot of money to get
started up and maybe it's easier
than doing something simpler could you
ever imagine what what
came out of your original
entrepreneurial
first steps uh no i could not possibly
have imagined
uh but uh you know and i don't know what
you're thinking was behind the forum
but i remember when i was really
thinking deeply about this and this was
sort of a
you know a graduate student project at
stanford and you know i talked to my
advisors like you know should i really
do this
entrepreneurial thing and you know might
not work out and i can just finish my
phd
and he said you know why not go for it
and then if it doesn't work out you come
back you finish your phd
which i'm still planning on doing but
anyway uh
you know there's like no big deal just
give it a shot
and and i think that that mentality
permeates uh silicon valley and i think
that's one of the strengths
that you know there's really not much
it's not viewed so negatively to try
something even if it doesn't work out
you've made ginormous amounts of money
what do you guys plan on doing the rest
of your life you've achieved so much
already
i think you know there are many
important things to life uh
you know aside from financial or career
success
[Music]
and in fact it's not necessarily the
ultimate
success that motivates you it's the
process of getting there and the
technologies or products that you build
or in whatever realms you may be in so
i'm not too concerned about finding
something to do
though i do think it'll be based on
doing things that i really enjoy
and not have some end goal in mind i
think as a kid
i was i always had a kind of scientific
curiosity
um i was always interested in
mathematics and i was i always enjoyed
still doing math problems and in fact my
undergrad i had a degree in both math
and computer science
and i think eventually i was really
inspired by computers
because of the amazing power that they
they give you i mean today's
pcs do a billion operations per second
i mean it's almost inconceivable
and i think that was the most inspiring
thing to me how you could
leverage that to actually produce
something that was you know that was
useful
beyond video games and things like that
eventually i went on to
to join the phd program computer science
at stanford
and those purely you know the interest
of
what can you do with all the world's
information now that it's online
that interest spawned google and that
was together with larry page who's my
co-founder and partner
the challenge of a problem or the
importance uh isn't that
related how likely you are to achieve it
and in fact even when you go after a
more ambitious goal even if you fail to
achieve that one
uh all the side effects that come along
the way uh can be that much more
uh rewarding and significant in their
own right
um and so you know i feel lucky that i
fell into
doing something that i feel really
matters
getting people information around the
world about
anything i
i wish there was a way to convey that to
you know to the world at large
obviously all of you already have this
religion
but it's very rewarding when you work on
something you think is going to make a
big difference
and yeah it's a little bit harder
but i think uh i think the passion that
one might bring with it
uh brings so much more energy to that
that you're more likely to succeed for
uh building a company and you guys are
doing great for 15 years
have you sort of like fundamentally
disagreed on something at all
over over the last 15 years and how did
you how do you resolve
where do i start
no i think if you
get to know somebody over a long period
of time we're working together for so
long and we
you know are committed to doing that you
don't like get
agitated about one little thing or the
other i don't know we
work it through and also generally we've
gotten
to think uh remarkably alike
which scares some people around us i
guess yeah and the other thing i mean we
know enough i guess that when we're
disagreeing i mean you make a lot of
calls that aren't obvious
so i mean if you're disagreeing it's
probably that it's not obvious what to
do
one is on deploying a service that's
going to serve millions of people
when we were at stanford we had you know
10 000 people using our service
or about 10 000 searches per day i
should say
and now we serve over 50 million
searches per day
and that scaling of infrastructure that
that's pretty challenging on a more
personal level i think
i'm now the president of google and we
have
about 170 people now and i think
managing managing people
and being emotionally sensitive and
all the skills you learn in terms of
communication
and keeping people motivated i think you
know that's been a challenge
and i've enjoyed learning that but
that's
that's an important and a hard thing to
learn the other thing that we've really
found
over time at google watching at other
companies watching many of you
is the importance of the development
cycle
and how you really need to be able to
churn
quickly through things and uh
because you know obviously
you're going to have failures you're
going to have the wrong
idea but it's important to fail quickly
i think
young people uh you know in some ways
their
their life is much easier than you know
sort of my life might have been
at that stage just you know for i think
all of us
uh you know having before
whatever if we're traveling to
switzerland it'd be a big stressful
thing how do you get in touch with
people before mobile phones arrange your
travel
figure out how to exchange your currency
you know
there are many things you know we can
whip our phones out and look up anything
and figure out how to get somewhere
um there are a lot of affordances that
are such conveniences today that make it
easy
but there is also uh a global stage that
makes it hard
actually uh you know because
if uh when i was in school
and i was on the math team or whatever
it was just compared to other kids in
the school and i
did quite well against them you know and
i found myself yeah i'm good at that i'm
good at that
uh i think i find younger folks today
are
their measures of themselves are always
especially you know the ambitious ones
are on this global stage said like well
you know i have to be you know number
one in the world at this or
that and i'm like you know that's a
really tall order
um and i think it can be discouraging in
a way
because if uh you know you know those
folks say well you know i'm number one
thousand in the world at this game which
which you know in my world would have
been an enormous achievement
because that means like you were
definitely the best in like your city
and your state and whatnot but
um but it's it's hard and i think you
know they get
there's a little bit of discouragement
so uh you know i would encourage young
folks to you know take chances and
pursue
their dreams and uh
you know try to silence out kind of the
voices that say well
actually there are like a thousand
startups trying to do whatever
self riding bicycles or whatever it is
they happen to be doing
and i think the key is to have fun in
your startup and not
from the beginning on to think of the
ipo which may bring you a billion
um that's keep and that was certainly
not your motivation to make it a success
yeah i mean i i certainly had no dreams
of such economic success
and uh i think you're exactly right i
think you should have
uh fun and not be so weighed down
by the weight of expectations um
that i think sort of this global network
unfortunately one of the downsides i
think it creates that weight
as a child i i was you know i had an
accent i came
to the us at the age of six and uh um so
i was teased and stuff in elementary
school and i don't think i was i don't
regard myself as you know being really
popular
going through school um but i
that was never that important to me and
i always had friends
i think if anything i've
i know i feel like i've gotten a gift by
by being in the states rather than
growing up in russia
and i know the hard times that my
parents went through there
and i'm very thankful uh that
that i was brought to the states and i
think
it just makes me appreciate my life much
more
larry and sergey almost got acquired
can you tell us a little bit about this
and i always wonder what the world
how the world might be different if that
had in fact
happened
well we had developed this technology we
called uh
page rank sadly not bryn rank but anyway
you probably would have sold better that
way but um
we developed this technology that we
found was useful for search
it by itself uh it wasn't really a
complete search engine what we had
kind of just searched titles of web
pages and
uh and ranked them quite well
uh but we showed it to a bunch of the
existing search companies back then
some of you might remember them you know
infoseek excite
lycos and
uh probably the greatest interest came
from excite and actually came from vinod
you were
the the investor in excite and we spent
a while
talking to them and talking talking to
you the node
yeah um you remember that uh in the end
um i don't think the management team
there was quite as excited
about it no pun intended um
but i remember we were you know we were
just there were four
of us at the time four grad students at
stanford
and i remember we fired off a note to
the node it was just like a little email
he said like you know we don't really
want to sell
but okay for 1.6 million dollars you got
a deal
and uh a few minutes later we got a
reply
and said that's a lot of dough but okay
we'll do it um
i know that's characteristic of node
right so then
ten minutes later scott one of the four
of us comes running in
laughing huge grin on his face he had
faked the reply
and uh
[Laughter]
yeah back then you know the ethics
around faking you
weren't quite the same anyway um
so he had that big joke and the deal
obviously never came to fruition and
we went our own way to build
gold search so the way i remember it we
actually agreed on a deal around three
hundred and fifty thousand dollars
what's this is typical
are you trying to renegotiate the stuff
i had a hard time getting the management
team
to agree that they should uh
acquire google i think he's saying that
they were having our time going to 350
and we
have a hard time changing our number
yeah that they felt they didn't need it
but
you know i i start here for one very
simple reason
there are many many instances where
things could have gone
either way and i'm really glad
they didn't acquire because the world
might have been a very very different
place
looking back in retrospect i feel like
it would have been really really sad
if in fact
larry and sergey had sold the company
and not pursued the vision and changed
the way
the world the way they have so
uh i've it's actually kind of an
interesting story because
the reason we didn't sell it is not so
much the money i mean like i don't know
we're like grad students
you know eating burritos or whatever so
like a million dollars was fair amounts
um the reason i think we really didn't
sell the company was that
we talked to all the search companies at
the time
and they just weren't interested in what
we were doing
and so and it was obviously like didn't
want to buy like you know this
company that didn't really have anything
without the people
so they wanted us but like we were like
well why are we going to work at this
place that doesn't believe in search
you know it's not going to cause
anything good to happen
something ultimately we didn't sell for
that reason just so they weren't
interested in it which same reason they
whatever had trouble getting to a
million dollars which i guess at the
time was a lot of money
um but uh but i think ultimately for me
it was just about
wanting to actually you know search
seemed pretty important it was about
actually wanting to do something in that
area
and didn't seem like that was going to
happen in these organizations
oracle's a very competitive company and
i think there are a lot of competitive
people at oracle and
i enjoy competition uh i think life is
is um
kind of a series a series of acts of
discovery
uh also and i think we're all interested
in our on our limits what we can
accomplish in life and discovering our
own limits
and we might find that in sport we might
find that in business
uh i think we're always you know uh
looking to you know discover new things
uh and new things about each other and
new things about ourselves
think things out for yourself come to
your own judgments don't simply
conform uh to conventional ways of
thinking conventional ways of dressing
conventional ways of acting that a lot
of this
a lot of things are are based on fashion
even morality at times is based on
fashion
it was once you know slavery was once
not considered not to be immoral
uh you know people are you know people
are shocked that
the uh the ancient greeks had slaves
that
that we had slavery in this country as
recently as you know 130 140 years ago
so there are more moral thoughts you
have to really go back to first
principles and think
things out for yourself whether they're
scientific principles or moral
principles or
business ideas or product ideas you have
to think things out for yourself
ideas good idea there are a lot of good
ideas
there are a lot of good ideas there are
a lot of good ideas
translating a good idea
into a great product is unbelievably
hard
there are so many details people accuse
steve of stealing
you know the macintosh from xerox you
know with the alto computer i was at
xerox park so i used the alto a lot
finishing the alto and turning that into
the macintosh
was enormously complicated and you
there were so many things that had to be
done that xerox had not done
there were a few good ideas in uh in the
xerox machine
but steve would translate good ideas not
always his good ideas
but he would translate good ideas into
finished product
unlike anyone in our industry you'd have
to i mean henry ford didn't invent the
car
but he made it cheap and he made it
popular and he made it accessible to the
american people
steve would translate good ideas into
finished
brilliant products we probably spend
less money in marketing than any
company our size in the world we have a
tiny marketing department
and everybody says why oracle's you know
all about sales and marketing
we are the largest employer of mit and
caltech engineers in the world
we are the largest employer of stanford
and
harvard and cmu mathematicians in the
world
we are overwhelmingly dominated by
engineering
at oracle the idea that we are a sales
and marketing company which people
will sometimes will write about quite
often is
ludicrous on the face of it because
all of our customers who buy oracle
already have it
and if you already have oracle there's
nothing a salesman can tell you about
how great it is to make you buy more
ge already uses it the defense
department always you already use it
all of our customers 98 of our sales or
more
are to existing oracle customers if we
don't have the right product
people don't buy more we will before the
acquisition we spend three billion
dollars a year in software engineering
the company is all about engineering
it's the only thing that works
suddenly we hit a wall we reach a
billion dollars in revenue
and we were having serious management
problems all over the place
and the people who were running the
company the billion dollar company were
the same people that
run the company when we were a 50
million dollar company 120th the size
and i had had an incredible sense of
loyalty
to those people who'd worked with me to
build oracle
and it was a very painful realization
in 1990 that i was going to have to
change the management team that
that the company had outgrown the
management uh
that people who are good at running a 50
million dollar company are not
necessarily those aren't the same skills
they're just different not one is better
or worse just entirely different skill
set
in running a 50 million dollar company
than a billion dollar company
and uh both skill sets are rare and
precious
but we needed a different group of
managers and virtually
the entire management team had to be
replaced and that means i had to ask
people
who i'd worked with for a decade to
leave by to fire people
uh and that was the most difficult
the most the most difficult thing i had
to do in in business
asking a bunch of people to
leave oracle our goal was to get we
started with four employees
and our goal was to get to 50 employees
and the goal really was
not so much to make a lot of money i
might i'm on i wanted
to me a lot of money in those days was i
want to own a house
i want to have a nice car and i wanted
to
work with interesting people and do
interesting things and i thought if i
could control my own environment have a
small consulting company
and oracle started out as a software
consulting company we work for tandem
computer if anyone remembers those guys
we work for ibm that we work for a lot
of uh
different tech companies in silicon
valley doing contract programming fixed
price contract programming and we
did pretty well actually and and again
the idea was just to have a
a small software contract software
company a bunch of
you know we thought we're hotshot
programmers and we thought we could make
a decent living doing just that
and quite by accident we built a product
my sister once said to me that
whenever i got too close to one of my
goals i immediately moved the goal posts
further away and i think in business you
can always do more
my objection to cloud computing is the
fact that everyone
this is you know cloud computing is not
only the future of computing eddie
it is the present and the entire past of
computing is all cloud
i mean salesforce.com has been around
for more than a decade
and so is netsuite you know uh
netsuite's been around longer than
salesforce
and it's people are saying well that's
cloud computing
uh you know google's now cloud computing
everyone's cloud computing
my objection to cloud computing was
everyone simply looks around
oh like yeah like i've always been doing
cloud computing
you know it's like yeah like 10 years
ago but cloud's computer
the term's only four years old yeah like
yeah but i you know
like everything is class in the cloud
now you know um
and i know my objection is the absurdity
the absurdity you don't like that no no
it's not that i don't like the idea of
what is i mean it's this nonsense
uh i mean the guy said oh it's in the
cloud well what is that
then you say are we dead oh yeah we're
dead if there's no hardware or software
in the cloud we are so
screwed but it's not water vapor
all it is is a computer attached to a
network what are you talking about
i mean what do you think what do you
think google runs on i'll ask you know
anybody did they run on water vapor
i mean cloud they have data
it's database how about the next
question operating systems
and memory and microprocessors
and the internet and all of a sudden
it's no it's none of that it's the cloud
what are you talking about now so
the vcs i love the vcs oh we only fun
is that cloud oh yeah oh whoa microsoft
word
change internet to cloud mass change
give it back to these nitwits on
sandhill road
today oracle employs around 150 000
people but when i started
it was not my intention to build a big
company
what happened well at first we did
exactly what we set out to do
hired the most talented software
engineers in silicon valley
we assembled an all-star team of gifted
programmers
who were among the best in the world at
what they did
that team plus one crazy idea
gave birth to a giant company i call it
a crazy idea
because at the time everyone told me it
was a crazy idea
the idea was to build the world's first
relational database
several theoretical papers about
relational databases had already been
published
and ibm was building a prototype in
their research labs
but back then the collective wisdom of
computer experts
was that while relational databases
could be
built they would never be fast enough to
be useful
i thought all those so-called
computer experts were wrong
and when you start telling people that
all the experts are wrong
at first they call you arrogant
and then they say you're crazy
so remember this graduates when people
start telling you
that you're crazy you just might be on
to the most
important innovation in your life there
are lots of times especially in the
early days
uh that were that were very very
difficult i think
i think the most difficult thing
experience i had was in 1990 when oracle
had its had its only lost quarter in
history and we've been in business for
20 years of this 20 years we lost money
one quarter
and we had a very difficult time um
because we had almost we doubled our
sales virtually every year for
for ten years nine out of ten years ten
out of eleven years it was really quite
an amazing run where the
fastest growing company in history still
we're still are the fastest growing
company in history
over a long period of time and
suddenly we'd hit a wall we would reach
a billion dollars in revenue
and we were having a serious management
problems all over the place
and the people who were running the
company the billion dollar company were
the same people that
run the company when we were a 15
million dollar company 120th the size
and i hadn't had an incredible sense of
loyalty to those to those people who had
worked with me to build oracle
and it was a very painful realization
in 1990 that i was going to have to
change the management team that the
company had outgrown
the management uh that people who are
good at running a 50 million dollar
company are not necessarily those aren't
the same skills
it's not they're just different not one
is better or worse the just entirely
different skill set
in running a 50 million company than a
billion dollar company
and uh both skill sets are rare and
precious
but we needed a different group of
managers and virtually
the entire management team had to be
replaced and that means i had to ask
people
who i'd worked with for a decade to
leave i had to fire people
and that was the most difficult
the most the most difficult thing i had
to do in in business
asking that yeah a bunch of people to
leave oracle i had no choice i never
even asked them to leave oracle or
everyone would have to leave oracle
because there wouldn't be any oracle
left
so it was in that sense it was a simple
choice
it was uh thousands of people worked at
oracle
uh they deserved the best leadership we
could find
and my primary my
primary responsibility was to the
company and
all all of the staff you know all of our
shareholders and all of our customers
and uh therefore i had to choose
and if i couldn't make that decision
then i had to go can you take me back
and tell me how you've done this
larry you're you're the godfather of
technology you founded this company
you're still
thriving you're still coming with all
these innovation things and i could see
how passionate you are you're beating
everybody um
and you came from such humble beginnings
grew up on the south side of chicago
dropped out of college now you have
collections of cars
jets private homes owning the island of
of lanai
tell me how you did it well i think i
think my favorite line is i had
all the disadvantages necessary for
success
you know uh when you're raised on the
south side of chicago
you probably want to move someplace
nicer and
i think if it doesn't kill you and makes
you stronger so
i've always been very ambitious i've
always been very curious
uh i was you know
moved to silicon valley right out of
right after i dropped out of college and
got a job as a computer program i
learned how to program when i was in
college
and i got a job as a computer programmer
and uh bummed around
yosemite valley teaching rock climbing
and and
um and leading river river trips
uh during my early 20s but the way i
supported myself was a computer
programmer
and i got involved with more and more
interesting and complicated
computer projects and decided to start
my own company microsoft
are they relevant anymore
they're they make a lot of money uh yeah
no i i i mean i think they're clearly
relevant
microsoft to me is if i divide the
computer industry into
two groups and i know for a long time i
you know kind of picked constantly was
picking a fight with microsoft
and now we're kind of constantly picking
a fight with ibm
because you've got to pick your your
enemies very carefully because you're
destined to be most like
those enemies you select throughout my
twenties i continued experimenting
trying different things racing bikes and
boats and constantly changing jobs
it didn't take me long to discover that
the most
interesting and rewarding programming
jobs were found at a cluster of
companies
located south of stanford university in
north of san jose
silicon valley was in its infancy
i was still in my 20s when i went to
work for my first
silicon valley startup amdahl
where we developed the world's fastest
mainframe computer
faster than anything ibm had next stop
was ampex
where we built the world's largest
digital data storage system
then on to precision instruments where
we built an
even larger data storage system this
time using
i was the vice president in charge of
software development
it was all very cutting edge and
challenging and cool
i liked my work most of the time but i
didn't love it
i searched and i searched but i just
could not find a software engineering
job
that i loved as much as i loved sailing
so i tried to create one
i put together a plan to start my own
company
that way i could completely control my
work environment
i would hire the most talented
programmers i knew
and we would all work together on the
most
interesting and challenging software
projects
my group my goal was to create the
perfect job
for me a job i truly loved
i never ex i never expected the company
to grow beyond 50 people
and you've got 440 000 customers 145
countries
um where do you go from here well
uh we want to make sure we beat amazon
and cloud database
so funny to hear you say that i mean
that's that's right very simple it's
very simple
uh it's just like playing basketball
if you know if you're playing basketball
you want to beat the warriors you want
to be you know
uh you want to win the championship yeah
so our job we have the best database in
the world
uh we've got to deliver it in the
context of
a a cloud that's as easy to use as
amazon
but secure and that's the key thing
amazon has great ease of use we've got
to marry that to security and all the
capabilities to the autonomous database
and we'll be great how would you
describe each phase
of the evolution of oracle and how would
you uh
sort of describe running each of those
phases you got to do this quick
i gotta well i mean and clearly being a
part of a company with four people and
being a
part of a company and by the way this
we're 85 000 now post
post merger with sun you know uh 100 uh
we think about
sun's got about 20 000 employees and you
know uh 25 000 employees we're about 105
000.
uh so uh 100 500 100 000 we're not sure
exactly
about that uh i mean clearly my job is
constantly changed
what has not changed is i ran
engineering at oracle on the first day
i run engineering today the one part of
the company i have always paid attention
to
and is always reported directly to me is
engineering not sales
not marketing not support and not
consulting not
services at various points in time lots
of other people have run
run those operations the back office
accountings
order management all of these things the
only thing that i've done
consistently during those 32 years is
run engineering because i believe
basically that once you reach you will
you know you'll win as
as we say at oracle it's amazing our
good products seem to do very well
and our bad products not so well
so the thing i focused on and i think we
get the most most leverage
is developing the right products
recruiting the right engineers and
having the right organization
during my california springs and summers
i spent most of my days in the high
sierras in yosemite valley
working as a river guide and a rock
climbing instructor
i loved those jobs but unfortunately
they didn't pay that well
so i also got a job working a couple of
days a week as a computer programmer
back in berkeley i had learned a program
in college
i didn't love programming but it was fun
and i was good at it and computer
program programming gave me the same
kind of satisfaction
as solving math problems and playing
chess
both things i enjoyed before before i
became a confused teenager
at this point in my life i thought i was
making real progress on my journey of
self-discovery
i had found a cause i had a couple of
jobs that i love
and one that was fun and paid the bills
i was pretty happy with my life
my wife was not
what she saw was a college dropout who
spent too much time in the mountains
doing
foolish things she wanted me to work
full time as a computer programmer
or go back to college and finish my
degree
we compromised sort of
i started taking classes at uc berkeley
i took several classes but the only one
i can remember
was a sailing class taught at berkeley
marina
once again i fell in love and began a
lifelong affair
with the limitless omnipotent pacific
ocean
when my class was over i wanted to buy a
sailboat
my wife said this was the single
stupidest idea
she had ever heard in her entire life
she accused me of being irresponsible
and she told me i lacked ambition
she kicked me out and then she divorced
me
[Music]
this was a pivotal moment in my life
my family was still mad at me for not
going to medical school
and now my wife was divorcing me because
i lacked ambition
it looked like a reoccurrence of the
same old problem
once again i was unable to live up to
the expectations of others
but this time i was not disappointed in
myself
for failing to be the person they
thought i should be
their dreams and my dreams were
different
i would never confuse the two of them
again i don't think my personality has
changed much since i was five years old
uh i think as i explained to the kids
just a little while ago
uh probably the single most
important aspect of my personality and
as far as determining my success
has been my uh my questioning of
conventional wisdom
my doubting of experts just because
they're experts
and questioning of authority and while
that can be very
very painful in terms of your
relationship with your parents and your
relationship with your teachers
it's enormously useful in life i don't
know if you know this there's about 3.38
million searches on our favorite search
engine with larry ellison
and i read them all i took them home at
night and i read all the searches and
and got nothing out of it but um
except except one thing did you know you
had a larry ellison
fan club on facebook it's not yours
there's 181 members
india each 181 that's it
that's it we have 105 000 employees
after this
position
i that's really depressing i i
i tried to find something on on google
and that was what i found you got 181
people that follow you and it's really
serious
yeah so you have to check it out good
god so larry let's uh let's see who are
these people
i don't know i'd have security check
them out
now i've got some special bonus clips
that i think you're gonna enjoy but
before that it's time for the
billionaire mindset
question of the day i wanna know what
was your single biggest takeaway
from this video and your plan of action
for the next week
also if you've already got your
billionaire mindset companion pdf
calendar
get ready for another amazing video
tomorrow or if you don't have it yet you
can get it for free
in the first line of the description
below and if you're enjoying this
billionaire mindset series give me a
hashtag
billionaire mindset in the comments
below so i can celebrate you
pick areas you think are interesting
that could be valuable or there's a lot
of activity
i was interested in links because i knew
no one else was really looking at the
links on the web
and i figured you know you could
probably do something with them and
i think that's true of many of these
areas where people people do interesting
things
i also think it's really important for
us when we're
when were working on this we had many
people sergey and i and a couple of
other people
who were tremendously worked
tremendously hard
and i think that was an important part
of
of making all this work certainly anyone
can say oh i want to build
you know a car that's going to cost five
dollars and go 500 miles an hour
and all that would be great i was
fortunate to
be at stanford and i was really
interested in data mining
which means analyzing large amounts of
data discovering
patterns and trends and at the same time
larry joined
uh stanford in 95 and he started
downloading the web
which is you know turns out to be the
most interesting data you can possibly
mine and our joint effort
just looking at the data out of out of
curiosity
we found that we had technology to do a
better job of search
and from that initial technology we got
really interested in the problem and we
realized how impactful
having great search can be and so we
built technology upon technology after
that
to bring google to where it is today and
we continue to develop lots of
technology
for tomorrow i was absolutely shocked uh
the the way we we treated the iraqis
you know we were incredibly aggressive
against them and uh
you know i mean was that really right
couldn't we have done that at different
i'm being sarcastic by the way
uh of course we're aggressive against
the iraqis they were you know they
invaded they invaded kuwait
they were threatening our oil supplies
they were threatening the world order
and of course we you know it was it was
the job of our armed forces
to defeat the enemy it is my job to you
know go out in the marketplace and win
and uh we you know run ads that compare
our products to the competitors products
we don't lie about that
we just say we can do this they can't we
name the comp the competition
we it's fact-based advertising and
uh we say very clearly that we you know
you know that we're faster and these
these tests prove it
we're more we're more reliable and these
tests prove it we're more economical and
so
we'll name it we'll name a competitor
that's considered
that that's not terribly you know uh
even though the facts are true
it's considered a little bit rude by
some people
uh i don't underst i don't think it's
immoral
uh i think that we are giving
true facts to customers giving valuable
information to customers so they can
they can make better decisions
uh it is bill gates's job to make
microsoft the biggest you know the
biggest company on earth that's what
he's paid for
it's my job for oracle to move from the
number two software company in the world
to become the number one software
company in the world
that's that's my job that's what i'm
paid for if i'm
if i'm not aggressive enough in the
pursuit of that if i'm not successful in
the pursuit of that
i should be gotten rid of if the general
running
uh desert storm is not aggressive enough
and successful enough in the pursuit of
that goal
he should be fired the corporation's
primary goal
is to defeat the competition in the
marketplace
i think that you know my primary
function
is to have oracle you know is to make
oracle successful
uh to make it a good and interesting
place to work
because we don't want people to leave
people this is this america people can
change jobs and they'll
go and people like to work with other
intelligent and interesting people they
like to do interesting things
uh and uh
you know or you know oracle offer you
know we have
fantastic salary scales i think we're
the highest paying company in silicon
valley where
we have you know wonder you know
wonderful benefits
all of these things but again don't
mistake any of that for altruism you
know
that is in our interest to retain our
employees
[Music]
you know their job my job is to build
better products in the competition
sell those products in the marketplace
and eventually supplant microsoft
and move from being number two to number
one if you want to sign up for the
entire billionaire mindset series for
free and get the companion bonus pdf
calendar
check the link right there next to me i
think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there